Speaker 1: All right. This you have to see and I
have to admit this, this gives me great pleasure.
Doug Mastriano is this big lie proponent who
was at the Capitol on January 6th, and he is
the Republican nominee for being the governor of
the state of Pennsylvania. It would be a disaster
if Doug Mastriano were to become the governor of
Pennsylvania. But the good news is his campaign
isn't doing very well, apparently desperate to
try to fix it. The Philadelphia Inquirer reports
that Doug Mastriano is now planning 40 days of
fasting and prayer to try to save his campaign.
I love this for two reasons. Number one. He's
losing and he's desperate. And that's great.
And it's good news for the people of Pennsylvania.
But also fasting and prayer aren't going to change
the polls for him. It's not actually going to
do anything. So I say do 80 days of fasting and
prayer. Of course, there's not 80 days left before
the before the election. The article writes,
The Republican gubernatorial candidate is losing
some support among Republican allies as his cash
strapped campaign turns to Twitter memes and
apparently divine intervention. These people are a
joke. It was billed as a blockbuster, but it ended
up a flop. If Doug Mastriano is big rally last
weekend were a movie, its Rotten Tomatoes score
would be in the single digits. Only a few dozen
supporters joined the Republican state senator on
the steps of the Capitol building in Harrisburg,
some of them members of a militia group. The
photos looked bad because it was bad and the
press coverage was brutal. So what is he doing
now, by the way? Here's a picture of the rally
I'm showing. It's like there's almost no one.
It looks like it's just intern orientation day
at the Capitol. Now, with the election
41 days away, the head of a conservative
group airing anti Schapiro ads. Remember,
SHAPIRO is the Democrat who we should all
just vote for. If you live in Pennsylvania
because he's a completely uncontroversial,
reasonable candidate, is questioning mastriano
his tactics, particularly his insistence on
campaigning within an echo chamber, etc., etc.. So
what is it that is going on now? On Monday night,
mastriano his campaign posted on Facebook a
photo of two hands under the words 40 days
of fasting and prayer with the date September 29
through November eight, Election Day interceding
for our elections, our state and our nation.
It stated, along with a verse from the book of
Isaiah Mastriano wrote in the post, Starting in
a few days, it'll be my honor to fast with you.
Now, as the article points out, it's unclear who
Mastriano expects to start fasting on Thursday,
but this is all part of this Christian nationalist
ideology. Now, of course, this isn't going to do
anything for him. And so my messages do it, do
it. The message to the voters is, don't assume
that we have this in the bag. No risks can
be taken. Here's the way that the polling is
looking right now. Mastriano versus Josh SHAPIRO
on average. On average, SHAPIRO is leading by 9.3,
almost a double digit lead. This is a major, major
deal because the risk, if Mastriano became the
governor is that Democrats lose the White House
in 2024. I know that some of you might find that
hyperbolic. It is not hyperbolic. Pennsylvania is
a state on which presidential elections can hinge.
Presidential elections are not going to
hinge on Rhode Island. It's not going to
hinge on South Dakota. We know how those are
going to go. Many scenarios have presidential
elections depending on Pennsylvania. If Doug
Mastriano wins in November and then in 2024,
a Democrat narrowly wins the presidential election
in Pennsylvania, be it joe biden or whoever is the
nominee. Mastriano will try to steal Pennsylvania
for republicans and so the consequences are
absolutely massive. So it is so great that
SHAPIRO is up nearly double digits, but.
Do not assume we have this in the bag. The risk is
too great. This one is just so, so important that
no risks can be taken. Now, as far as Josh SHAPIRO
and we're going to have coverage of the Mastriano
versus SHAPIRO debate, let me remind myself when
that is. Let's see. I'm checking out my calendar.
It is. I don't know what it is. Is it tomorrow? No
work. I'll let you know when that debate is. Okay.
We're going to have the debate. Josh SHAPIRO is
not a Democrat that Pennsylvanians have to kind of
turn their nose up and say, well, I'm reluctantly
voting for Josh SHAPIRO. He's not the most
progressive Democratic candidate, but he's super
smart. He's reasonable. He's common sense. He's
completely uncontroversial. He's actually a fine
choice for governor of Pennsylvania. So it's all
laughable. The prayers not going to get mastriano
to catch up. The ten point deficit. The fasting
certainly is not. Let them do it. Encourage
them to do it. But let's not assume that this
is in the bag because it is so important a race
and we don't want to give them any opportunity.